Voiceover: What I want
to do is this video,
is dig a little bit
deeper into the deficit.
Just so that you can
get the data yourself,
they're all available at this document
which is hosted by the
Department of Treasury
so you know that I'm not
making up these numbers.
Just to review, the
deficit is really a measure
of how much you are
overspending in any given year.
If you look at the deficit, and I'm
going to focus on 2010 in this video,
in 2010, the government spent,
so the spending for
the government in 2010,
was about $3.5 to $3.6 trillion dollars,
and it brought in in mainly tax revenues,
but it has a few other sources,
but mainly tax revenues, it brought
in about $2.2 trillion dollars.
Based on this the overspending,
or the amount of spending beyond
the revenues, or the deficit,
the deficit in 2010 was
$1.3 trillion dollars.
What I want to be clear on,
this is only one way to account
for spending versus revenues.
This is not the way that most
companies would primarily
report their own income
over the course of the
year, or their own cost,
or their own loss over
the course of the year.
Most companies would not just have
to account for their cash outlays.
That's all we're considering in
this $3.5 to $3.6 trillion dollars.
A traditional company would
also have to include any other
liabilities or any other
obligations they're taking on.
For example, if I hire you and I promise
to pay you $50,000 over the
course of the next year,
and I'm going to pay them to you in cash,
but I also promise that when you retire,
I'm going to pay you $10,000.
I'm going to give you a
$10,000 per year pension.
On a traditional income statement,
I would not just expense the $50,000.
I would definitely put
that in my expenses,
and the government would
put that in their expenses,
but I would also have to account
for this liability that I'm taking on.
I would also have to say,
"Look, in order for me to
be able to afford a $10,000
"pension at some future date,
I have to make some estimates
"about when you would retire
and how long you would live,
"and what interest I could get
on money, and all of the rest."
But I would have to say I would have
to set aside some amount of money
so that in the future I
can meet that obligation.
Maybe I have to set
aside $2,000 this year,
and hope it grows properly over the course
of the next 20-30 years until you retire
so that I can afford to pay you that much.
Who knows? But I would
also have to account
for it right here, that extra liability.
The government, in the
calculation of the deficit,
does not account for that extra liability.
It is taking on other liabilities.
It is making these pension
promises to government employees.
It has obligations to the veterans
and Veteran's Affairs and all of that.
That is not accounted for in the deficit.
It is accounted for in the gross costs.
You see here, we said when
we look at just the budget,
we're talking $3.5 to
$3.6 trillion dollars.
That's direct cash outlays,
or mostly direct cash outlays.
If you include all of this other stuff,
then it balloons to $4.5 trillion
dollars, $4.5 trillion dollars.
In a previous video I mentioned
that the government right now
for every dollar that it's spending,
it has to borrow 40 cents of that dollar.
If you really think about the
total obligations that it has,
and the total obligations
being $4.5 trillion took on,
viewed that way it only
has about half of that.
It only has about half of
that coming in in revenue.
So every dollar in revenue
the government is taking
on an equal amount of
obligations that year.
Some of that is going to express
itself in terms of increased debt,
and some of that is just going to
show up as increased obligations.
You can see both of those
things are increasing
year after year after year,
and depending on who you talk to
which side of the political spectrum,
some people will blame it on Bush.
They'll say, "Look at this." The
spending increased under Obama,
which someone on the right would say.
But then someone on the left would say,
"Yes, but the spending increased
"because we have to do
all of these bailouts.
"The economy started to
tank at the end of 2008.
"We have to do all of
these emergency things."
As soon as the economy tanks,
you automatically, the deficit
position gets worse because
you bring in less revenue.
Not only do you bring in less revenue
because corporate profits are
down, fewer people are employed,
people start earning less, but
you also have higher expenses
because all of these automatic
obligations kick into effect;
unemployment benefits, Social
Security benefits, Medicare benefits.
Those increase so deficits
naturally get worse,
but the whole point here
is to say regardless
of what party you're on,
things are getting worse,
and they don't seem to be getting better.
Generally, you'll always
see this net operating cost,
sometimes the net operating
costs will look lower
than the actual deficit
like it did in 2008.
That's because there would
be some type of actuarial
or accounting reestimate
of the future obligations
maybe the pension obligations or whatever.
But in most years, we're taking on more
obligations than just our cash outlays.
That's why you see the
operating costs so much higher
than just the pure
deficit right over here.
This chart right over here actually goes
into what the difference
is, the actual difference.
You see that it's mainly
things like liabilities
for veteran's compensation, military
and civilian employee benefits,
government sponsored enterprises.
There is some downward
revision of the TARP.
I don't think you can see that.
All of a sudden you realize
that the TARP is going
to cost us more in the future than
you thought it was going to be.
Even though you don't spend
that $86 billion this year,
you realize that you have an
$86 billion higher obligation.
If you add all of these, or I
guess you subtract all of these
from the budget deficit, then you're going
to get the net operating costs.
You might already find that depressing,
but the point of this video is actually,
that's just the beginning, because
if you look at where we're going,
the trajectory, it gets
even more depressing
because not only do we have
this huge budget deficit,
or this huge operating cost,
this loss I guess you could
say on an annual basis,
but it's going to get worse
and it's going to get worse
not just from the overspending,
not just from the overspending
on the government programs,
and defense and all of that,
but because our debt is increasing
so much that the interest,
the amount we spend on interest
is only going to increase.
That just makes matters worse.
The more you spend on interest,
the larger your deficits.
The larger your deficits,
the more you have to borrow,
the more you have to spend on interest.
This is a long time line right
here. It goes out to 2080,
but it's pretty clear that something,
something is going to give.
As a percentage of GDP, the government,
the size of the government
has historically been
around this depending on
different periods in history,
but in the recent past
it's been in the 20% range.
If you just let things go
the way they're going to go,
and a lot of these are
kind of mandatory spending,
things we've already
obligated ourselves to,
or what we think we've
it looks like the size of
the government is really
just going to take over the economy.
It's going to grow over
the next 20-30 years
to 30%, 35%, 40% of the entire economy.
If that by itself is not scary
or depressing enough for you,
then we just have to look at
this chart right over here.
We've already gone over
some of this chart.
This is the gross costs. This is
the total amount we're spending,
outlays, cash outlays and other
obligations we're taking on,
and accounting for it in
some way in the present.
Then you have the taxes
that you're bringing in,
and you see that this
is your net operating
cost that we calculated already.
Then it shows your assets,
the assets of the government,
mainly buildings and land
and things like that.
The government has a lot
of nice land and buildings.
Then you also see property, plant
and equipment, and all of that;
aircraft carriers,
whatever you want to throw
into the mix right over here.
Then you see the debt and there's
been a lot of talk of the debt,
but you might be saying,
"Wait. Even in 2010,
"right now as we hit the debt
ceiling we have $14.3 trillion,
"but didn't we have like $13.
something trillion in debt in 2010?
"Why does this only say $9 trillion?"
That's because we had
another $4 trillion in debt
that is not held by the public.
This is just debt held by the public.
The public includes things
like foreign governments,
but there's another $4
trillion that is held
by the government itself so
that is not accounted for.
That $4 trillion is mainly excess funds
from the Social Security Trust that
are all invested in treasuries,
but the government, at the
end of the day, is responsible
for the Social Security Trust.
So it is not accounted
for right over here.
You have $9 trillion there.
You have another $6 trillion
that is seldom talked about
which is benefits for federal
employees and veterans.
That's right over here,
so huge obligation.
A total of $16 trillion in liabilities.
If that by itself
doesn't scare you enough,
or doesn't depress you enough,
we just have to go down a
few lines on the statement,
and you'll see something that does.
This right here is the
expected, or the present value
of the obligations for social insurance.
The way that they talk
about social insurance,
it's both social security
and things like Medicare.
These things that we've
promised we would pay to people
in the future at least
that we've told people
that we will pay them in the future.
The present value, and
the easiest way to think
about present value, and
I've done videos that go
into a little bit more depth on that is
how much money given some assumptions,
if you assume that if I put money aside,
and that money grows at some rate,
how much money would I have to put aside
in order to fund those obligations?
This value is over the next 75 years,
and I want to make it clear.
You might say, "Oh, 75 years, of course,
"that's going to be a huge number."
But remember, we're assuming
that we can grow money.
We're assuming that
obligations that are 75 years
from now that if i have to pay
someone $10 75 years from now,
I don't have to put $10 aside.
I might only have to put
50 cents or a dollar aside
and assume that that 50 cents or
dollar will grow by some percentage
so that by the time 75 years go
by, I'll actually have that $10.
This is actually a discounted value.
This is assuming that the money
that you could set aside today
that the obligation
today, that it would grow
to actually fulfill the actual
amount that you have to pay.
This should scare you.
These are huge numbers.
This close group are what they
call the current participants.
We could read the footnotes.
Includes current participants receiving
and/or are eligible to receive
benefits for the Social Security
and Medicare programs ages 15 and over
at the start of the 75
year projection period.
That's $43 trillion. Then open group.
They have current and future participants.
This is slightly lower
because it's including
people who are going to be
paying into the program,
and not necessarily
taking out of the program.
but it's still a huge, huge liability.
It's twice as big as
the official liabilities
that the government takes on.